there's a UK TV quiz show called
University Challenge in which teams from
two different UK universities are
fighting against each other to answer
general knowledge questions and it's a
really popular show and it's the
ambition of a lot of undergraduates to
be on University Challenge team when I
was a student applied to be in my
colleges team and I wasn't good enough
and I was really disappointed so I
recently watched the opening credits and
I was really pleased to see a periodic
table but then if I when I look
carefully I was really disappointed
because their table is wrong it's not
the most current one the important new
super-heavy elements that all have their
own names look here on my tie we've got
hassium meitnerium darmstadtium
roentgenium these all have names which
have real significance scientists have
struggled for years to create these and
on the periodic table on their credits
they're just numbers now of course they
could argue there's a historic periodic
table but it's not it's 10 to 15 years
out-of-date
so it's not old enough to be historic
my car's 11 years old and it isn't
historic yet it's just a bit old and
their periodic table is the same so I
think it's time for an update they
should perhaps something that's new and
exciting and up-to-date I think that the
periodic table doesn't change all that
frequently though there have been quite
a few changes in the three years that
we've had periodic videos going I don't
think it's very difficult for people to
update their credits after all most
programs update their credits every two
or three years anyway
I'm usually okay in the chemistry
questions I'm hopeless with sport or
music pop music and so I'm not really a
very good team member because for one of
those teams you want somebody who's a
good chemist but also knows all the
names of the opera's knows all the
football teams and everything else a
good all-rounder and I don't know any of
that